[Musique]
ici à Detroit, une ville de guerre, le côté ouest de la ville
à 150 pâtés de maisons est interdit
à tout le monde.  les parachutistes de l'armée les
gardes nationaux la police d'état et locale
continuent la lutte contre
une poignée de cyber bonjour tout va
bien pas de problème bon je dormirai quand
ils commenceront à rouler hé les gars hé je
vais à l'épicerie de l'autre côté de la
rue je suis venu porter  cadeaux
merci ouais bien sûr
ne poussez pas votre lit c'est une zone de guerre là-
bas ils détruisent la ville
Je pense que le noir, c'est presque comme si le
téléphone d'une fille sonnait.
ne soyons pas stupides dans cette situation
vous devez me dire où est l'arme
j'ai toute la nuit les gens me disent exactement
ce qui se passe
et
vous pensez que nous bluffons
nous ne vous bloquons
pas